Hasebe-san and the Souvenir Ward don't have a problem with that.
There's no guarantee that you won't score points, right?
No, I'm a
fool.
No, I don't
think it's intriguing The
part where you can't calm down
Now that we've finished talking about the test,
please shut up
Hey, hey
, you're not making fun of me in your heart
Three things are going to kill you, so calm down What do you think?  Do
n't say something like a comfort car If I was a family, I
could take
responsibility Say responsibility
, I can't do what I'm doing right now There are things I can do and
things
I ca
n't
do  Ah, I can't help
it If I continue to quarrel and break up,
you'll feel bad about yourself later. First of all,
let's apologize to Mr. Kushida.
I don't think that's what you said without dark disturbing
people.Eh, it's not like I'm apologizing, but I'm going
to let you clean my uniform.
If that's not the case, don't
cry me